- So you've been pretty
open about your hearing loss
and tell everybody that
doesn't know, what happened?
- I've been diagnosed with a
thing called Meniere's disease
and I was diagnosed like thirty years ago.
I lost my right ear and
had mounts of vertigo
and lost my hearing in my right
ear about thirty years ago.
I lost eighty percent of it.
And I lived, existed on
one ear, for you know,
most of this time.
Then two years ago, two years and a month,
I lost my left ear.
(audience shock)
- And now although it
fluctuates occasionally
which gives me hope.
- Yeah.
- It's really bad most of the time
and the worst part is
that I can't hear music.
- As a musician, oh
- And music is so much harder
to listen to than speech.
I can hear speech a little
bit with hearing aids
I wear hearing aids
- Mhm
- And all that.
And I could Bluetooth
through my phone and all that
but music, the real problem
is that my left side,
the lower frequencies
just fall of the cliff
and I have residence or distortion.
- [Kelly} Mhm.
So, I can't hear a base part that would go
(bass noise)
it goes
(loud, distorted, bass noise)
- [Kelly] Oh, man.
- [Guest] Like it's a blown speaker
- Yeah, like it's distorted.
- I went to a famous EMT
guy, when I first had it
And he said well, he looks at me and says
"Well, get use to it."
when I lost the one ear.
- Well that's some, bed side table manner.
I'm like wow.
(laughing)
- I said you are kidding me
I said I'm a musician, I'm worried about
he says look, "Brian Wilson had one ear,
Jimmy Hendricks had one ear."
The guy said,
"I have one ear and I've been
in a barber shop quartet."
I said really?
- I love that, you
probably needed that guy,
you needed that guy in that moment.
- I did.
- Yeah, just so it's like okay,
I'm going to crawl out of this.
This is not what I wanted.
- Not good for mixing
records, stereo, y'know...
- Yeah, yeah.
(failed stereo sounds)
There's no stereo.
- You only got the one.
(laughing)